[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a japanese movie called the
seeds of happiness spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
at the start of the movie a couple david
and nikki are having dinner at a fancy
restaurant while both of them are
enjoying their food nicki suddenly
questions david if he is all right
unexpectedly david takes out a ring from
his pocket and proposes to nikki to
marry him startled by the unexpected
proposal nicki just stares at him with
confused eyes and soon looks away
because of this an awkward david
suggests nikki take her time with the
decision
after a while nikki leaves the place
alone and on her way back home she comes
across a flower shop the shop has seeds
of happiness on sale and this makes
nikki curious the next morning nikki is
planting one of the seeds inside her
garden here we get to know that nicki
has been frustrated as of late so she
has bought the seeds in hopes of
changing her sad and boring life later
at the office a colleague at work
inquires nicki if she answered david's
proposal to which she says no when the
colleague questions her if there is any
problem with david nikki again says no
the colleague then mentions that the two
are a perfect match for each other as
they have been dating for the last three
years despite this nikki still seems
skeptical about something after
returning from work while nikki is
collecting her clothes she notices a
hand coming out from her garden it is
the same spot where she planted the seed
of happiness when she approaches the
hand and starts digging near it she
suddenly finds a girl and screams in
horror in the next scene the same girl
who has a plant growing out of her head
cleans herself up while a shocked nikki
stares at her in disbelief she asks the
girl about her identity but the latter
simply ignores her question the little
girl then approaches nikki's family
picture and exclaims that she missed it
very much hearing this nikki gets
confused and she again asks the girl
about her identity this time the girl
replies that she is joanna nikki's
mother she further mentions that she
came to existence because of the magic
seed that nikki had planted taken aback
by the revelation nikki quickly grabs
the magic seed packet and takes a look
through it however she fails to find
anything unusual so she suspects the
little girl of lying to her just then
the little girl starts spitting facts
about nikki's personal life which only
she would know she mentions her date of
birth weight at birth and even her
favorite food this stuns nikki but even
now she is skeptical about the girl's
story as the two are talking nikki's
stomach suddenly starts rumbling and the
little girl decides to make her favorite
dish she then climbs on a chair and
starts preparing the ingredients while
the little girl is at it she mistakenly
injures her finger but when nicki rushes
to check on her she finds a green liquid
instead of blood this indicates that the
little girl is totally a plant
after a while the food is finally served
and when nikki takes a bite of it she
realizes that the taste is familiar this
assures nicki that the little girl is
indeed her mother she takes some time to
process the information and asks joanna
if she is going to eat however joanna
replies that she cannot eat food as she
is a plant she then asks nikki about her
father and nicki replies that he has
been busy traveling abroad after the
short mom-daughter conversation joanna
decides i'm taking a bath but as soon as
she comes in contact with water she
starts screaming hearing this nikki
immediately rushes to the bathroom and
finds joanna struggling to contain the
water shower when nikki turns off the
tap she gets startled to see that joanna
has grown into a teenager turns out that
the plant girl grows every time she
comes in contact with water at night
nikki lends some of her clothes to
joanna and as they are preparing to
sleep she suddenly gets a notification
upon checking her phone she finds a text
from david who suggests she take her
time with the decision joanna also reads
the text and excitedly asks her daughter
if she has been proposed to however
nikki replies that it is personal and
she should stay out of it despite this
joanna urges her daughter for an answer
left with no other choice nicki reveals
that she has been proposed to but hasn't
decided about her answer yet being the
good mother that she is joanna decides
to sleep with her daughter and discuss
the whole matter with her but nikki
pulls her away and orders her to sleep
on the couch outside although distraught
joanna agrees and leaves the room
outside while joanna is contemplating
her life choices she suddenly notices
the magic seed packet and starts
inspecting it inside it she finds a note
and after reading it she becomes sad
joanna then chucks the note inside the
dustbin and goes to sleep in the next
scene while nikki is walking around her
office she hears her nosy colleague
talking to joanna the two are discussing
nikki's boyfriend david nikki hurriedly
approaches them and tells her colleague
that joanna is her cousin she then grabs
joanna and pulls her away but just then
david emerges from the elevator joanna
immediately recognizes him and starts
asking him several questions embarrassed
nikki again lies about the girl's
identity and takes her away the duo then
enters a private room and nikki berates
joanna for her actions after apologizing
joanna expresses that david is a perfect
match for her and hence she should
really think about the proposal however
nikki replies that everything is not as
simple as it seems hearing this joanna
asks her daughter if she truly likes
david to which she replies yes this
delights joanna and soon she starts
reminiscing about nikki's childhood
after this the movie goes into a
flashback it is nikki's sixth birthday
and both her parents are there to
celebrate it nikki seems really excited
about her present and when joanna hands
it over to her she starts unwrapping it
immediately however her expression
quickly changes when she finds a
five-piece makeup set instead of the
magic ring that she had requested joanna
then reveals that the magic ring had
been sold out and hence she got her the
makeup kit hearing this little nikki
acts as if she likes the gift but the
disappointment is clearly visible on her
face this bothers joanna so she
approaches nikki to inform her that she
doesn't have to force herself to like
the gift she then apologizes for not
fulfilling the little girl's wish and
suggests she follow her heart and tell
the truth after a bit of thinking nikki
concedes that she still wants the magic
ring and joanna vows to get it for her
after the conversation joanna heads out
in search of the ring the scene then
changes to the present where joanna
mentions that she is still proud of her
daughter as she followed her heart but
before she can continue the story she is
stopped by nicki who exclaims that she
doesn't want to hear any more of it
following this she leaves the room
leaving joanna sad at night while nikki
is walking back home she starts
remembering the rest of the story where
her mother is in an icu bed a young
nicki can only watch in horror as her
mother fights for her life surprisingly
she has the magic ring with her after
reaching home nikki proceeds to get
changed but just then she hears some
noises coming from her bedroom she
rushes upstairs and finds joanna going
through her personal belongings when
nikki tries to stop her joanna suddenly
asks if she still has the magic ring
hearing this nikki becomes silent for a
while after coming out of her emotional
state she takes out the ring from a
drawer and hands it to joanna delighted
that the ring still exists joanna says
that it brings back special memories
from the past however when she asks her
daughter if she remembers the memories
nikki gets enraged saying that she
doesn't want to remember anything about
it she then snatches the ring from
joanna's hand and shouts that if it
weren't for the stupid ring her mother
wouldn't have gone out and died in an
accident hence to this day nikki still
blames herself for her mother's death
following this a distraught nikki throws
the ring out of a window saying that she
doesn't need it anymore she then claims
that she doesn't deserve any happiness
in life this is the reason why she
doesn't want to get married with anyone
as she fears that she will ruin
someone's life again joanna tries her
best to console her daughter but nikki
cuts her short she then orders that
joanna go away saying that her life was
happier before she came into existence
seeing her daughter devastated joanna
obliges and leaves in the next scene we
are shown that nikki has been in her bed
all day long tired of overthinking she
decides to take a walk but finds out
that it is raining heavily she heads
downstairs to apologize to joanna but
fails to find her just then it dawns on
nicki that the heavy rain might have
drenched joanna fearing that she will
lose her mother again she decides to
head outside but accidentally knocks the
dustbin over spilling all of its
contents as nikki collects the trash she
notices the same note from the magic
seed packet the note reveals that the
lifespan of the flower is a single week
but over watering may result in
immediate growth and shortened lifespan
in a panic nikki rushes out of her house
with an umbrella and finds joanna
searching for something near a tree when
nikki approaches joanna she is shocked
to find out that her mother has grown to
her original state because of this nikki
calls her mom for the first time joanna
is delighted by the surprise but she
soon continues her search nikki requests
that they go inside and talk but joanna
stresses that she will only go back once
she finds the ring because it is special
to her nicki again tries to persuade her
mentioning that her lifespan will be
shortened if she stays in the rain but
joanna is adamant on finding the ring
first after a bit of searching joanna
eventually does find the ring and hands
it over to nikki she then expresses her
happiness at finally delivering the gift
to her daughter following this nikki
tries to take her mother inside but it's
too late a flower petal from joanna's
head suddenly falls down indicating that
her lifespan is about to end before
nicki has a chance to react joanna gets
dizzy and loses her balance however even
in her final stages she continues to
express her affection for her only child
joanna mentions that she doesn't regret
going out to get the ring and if given
the chance she would do it over and over
again
if i were her i would have maybe waited
for the next day after joanna apologizes
to her daughter for leaving her with
painful memories nikki assures her that
she has always missed her mother as the
two get emotional some more flower
petals fall down from joanna's head with
her last breath she mentions that she is
proud to be the mother of a wonderful
girl like nikki joanna then requests her
daughter to remain happy and passes away
in her arms as the rain continues
pouring heavily in the next scene nikki
follows her mother's wish and finally
gets married to david after exchanging
their vows the entire crowd applauds
them among the crowd nikki's father is
also present along with a picture of the
late joanna the movie ends as nikki
gazes at her late mother's picture and
says the words thank you mom
kids when you find the woman you want to
marry just make sure you resurrect her
dead mother in the form of a plant and
let them work it out subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching